that timeline makes a lot of sense
because the great awokening in the media
happened it started it had a very so
sociologists have found that had like a
very specific starting point which was
around 2011 2012 when the New York Times
erected its paywall not coincidentally
that's when you started to see woke
terminology start to just absolutely
Skyrocket across the major mainstream
liberal news media so sociologists have
literally trawled The Archives of the
New York Times And The Washington Post
and NPR and the Atlantic and all these
outlets and they found that words like
oppression marginalization the word
people of color near the word oppression
or marginalization white privilege it's
like a hockey stick like they were kind
of like this until 2011 2012 they
started to totally Skyrocket and what
happened in 2015 was white liberals
their their opinion as it was polled by
sociologists so public opinion among
white liberals started to outpace public
opinion of blacks and Latinos in terms
of how radical it was on issues of race
so that that impact of the skyrocketing
of the use of these terms in the liberal
media by three years later four years
later by 2015 it had this huge impact on
public opinion of white liberals to
where they became much more extreme in
their views on Race than blacks and
Latinos and started using this very
academic language and that's kind of
where the Great Awakening started did
you see that one study that showed
liberals white progressives are the only
racial group in the United States with
an out-group preference yes so what that
means is uh people who are Hispanic or
Latino
slightly tend to prefer being around
people who are Hispanic or Latino black
people slightly it's like I think you
know 18 of a hundred so it's like it's
low but it exists white conservatives
slightly prefer to be around white
conservatives and liberals prefer not to
be around white people
did you know this is weird yeah there's
also a correlation with the graph that
you were mentioning that I've been
seeing online with of course Occupy Wall
Street and some people theorizing that
this was the corporate media's response
towards people going against the big
Banks going against the big institutions
that have failed them going against the
banker bailouts that have redistributed
wealth to the very rich taken away from
the very poor and from from what I'm
seeing it's a perspective of holy crap
people are catching on to what we're
doing we need to divide and conquer them
therefore let's inject this language
which will help create do that do you
think that that is a possible Theory
okay so I'll give you a less
conspiratorial version and then you'll
tell me if you if you find it convincing
enough to abandon the more delicious
conspiratorial version which I could
totally see why that's like a satisfying
way to think about it because and I
totally agree that this great awokening
moral Panic about race is a distraction
from the real divide In America which is
the disgusting levels of income
inequality and the class divide so I
agree with that part of it I do per
personally think from a from the point
of view of the news media this was much
more about the digital revolution in
terms of media I think it coincided with
the New York Times erecting its paywall
because what they started to do is what
all of us in digital media do which is
be able to track what terms people
clicked on what terms made them close
the browser you know what words made
them share things what words made them
engage online and of course engagement
is the big measure of success for
digital media and so I think that
there's a much less kind of big picture
there's just like a profit margin to
where journalists have always been more
liberal than Americans at large but here
you had their corporation saying no no
chase that you know racial liberalism
because our audience likes it I would
even go just a little bit further and
say maybe the algorithms that favored
that were also manipulated because of
that larger possible conspiracy but same
same reason we could also live in a
reality where both were true at the same
yeah well no look look so so I wasn't
convincing enough to have been no you're
right
Luke's wrong you're right because I've
talked about this too
it's not just the media organizations
were making money said Facebook was as
well yes so Facebook and incentivized in
their algorithms terms like these now
I'm not saying I know for a fact they
literally said we want this to appear
more but if the algorithm favors if the
algorithm is simply designed if someone
clicks something show it more then terms
that made people angry Injustice were
more likely to be shared so this did a
couple things
all of a sudden we saw the rise of the
digital blog we saw the Huffington Post
BuzzFeed when uh I as I often explain
for those who have heard it forgive me
but for those who haven't
if you write an article it says police
are racist you'll get X views if you
write an article saying police are
sexist you'll get why views but if you
write an article saying police are
sexist and racist those two keywords
gives you an exponential boost you'll
get a bonus to the amount of traffic
because when an article gets a
substantial amount of play the algorithm
boosts it more so now that you're
hitting two different communities the
anti-racism and the anti-sexism
community Facebook says oh wow this one
got a hundred thousand show it to
another twenty thousand see what happens
meh nothing this one got a hundred
thousand do the same thing but when this
article gets two hundred thousand whoa
show it to another hundred thousand keep
showing it that one's getting way more
traffic than normal
so the combination of terms gave rise to
intersectionality which was a big
component in the precursor of the
culture War which then resulted in a lot
of this you know wokeness but another
really obvious uh component
you're familiar with gamergate yes so I
can't tell you everything about
gamergate now now nearly 10 almost 10
years on what I can say is
a a video game publication accusing a
person of being racist makes no sense
but what happens is if you are tasked
hey we're going to make a video game
website what can you really write about
well some of these sites would be like
okay a new game came out we got a new
Zelda game
um let's write all the ticks and uh all
the tricks and tips all of the items you
can get and then what then what the next
day you come into work and the editor
goes what are you going to write about
well I just finished writing about the
Zelda game and they're like we need
articles I don't care what's going on uh
this developer tweeted the joke that's
offensive write it up and then all of a
sudden they found the easiest way to get
traffic was
can we accuse someone of being a bad
person and it somehow relates to video
games and then all of a sudden you have
these these Outlets being like if we are
going to keep writing news every single
day we need an angle and that's a result
of a dying but just really dying art
form um because video game gameplay
footage on YouTube took over so now if
you want to watch gameplay review you
don't read about it you watch it on TV
and they were just scraping for life
there's an important question to answer
here does the algorithm run us or do we
run the algorithm so it's like a did the
chicken come or the Egg coming
I would argue that there are people tied
into a lot of these bigger big Tech
social media companies that are doing
social human experimentation are doing
uh psychological experiments just like
Facebook has done and and knowingly
conducted controlling our emotions and I
think there is even a bigger profit
motive to make someone feel lonely to
feel sad to feel depressed and I think
there is a correlation between our
Mental Health Decline and of course the
onset and prominence of big Tech social
media so I I would say that I believe
that both could be true but I think what
is more prevalent is the algorithm uh
running us that's my perspective that's
how I see my experiences you see it
differently I agree with you yeah that's
true it's not the people running us it's
definitely a combination between
self-fulfilling creation we do have the
article this is from the guardian
Facebook sorry almost for secret
psychological experiment on users
they've been doing this they're probably
still doing it Facebook knows when you
poop but what happens is Facebook
YouTube Twitter whoever makes an
algorithm they're aiming for an outcome
they can't program for this is the
danger of I think one big dangers of AI
but so YouTube says we want content on
YouTube that is long form with the high
retention rate that hits issues subjects
matter people like how do we do that
okay if someone clicks the video that's
a good sign if someone watches for a
long time that's a good sign and then
we'll show everybody the same words that
keep getting clicked what happens
YouTube starts promoting Hitler doing
Tai Chi with the Incredible Hulk singing
nursery rhymes yes yes because it was
babies who watched the most and just
watched 100 of videos because they don't
touch anything oh this is what happens
when a human programs an algorithm and
then lets it run the algorithm goes wild
so we ended up like everything we're
seeing right now Rachel Maddow right
Russia Russia Russia Russia it's called
audience capture Rachel Maddow can't
admit she was wrong about it so she just
elides the controversy she ignores it
now she's coming out and claiming that
Republicans forged electoral documents
the reality is as is typical with any
contentious election Republican electors
in 20 in 2020
filled out their uh electoral slates
sent them to the government that's it
the same thing happened in 1960 with
Hawaii Nixon and Kennedy well Rachel
Maddow could tell you the truth
but then she won't get traffic then her
audience won't like what she has to say
so she just plays into that narrative
humans become servants to the algorithm
after the algorithm chooses nonsense to
be popular the human plays along with it
and pushes that same garbage okay so I
think I disagree with you guys I think
that the well okay from the point of
view that I have which is the point of
view of elite Media or rather mainstream
you know Legacy Media to me it seems
like they have very much abandoned the
idea of like Mass readership the New
York Times is no longer going for a mass
readership they're going for elite
Highly Educated liberals based on the
subscriber model so now they only have
to satisfy those I think right now they
have seven million we don't disagree
interesting we agree so but I think you
can't like the when you have such a
small everybody now all the liberal
Outlets including CNN all these people
are going for the same they all they
don't want all Americans watching they
want 10 million affluent liberals like
that's and so to like it's those people
are very specific in terms of what
they're looking for we we agree we're
agreeing yeah I'm saying Rachel Maddow
has a very small and specific audience
that you can't betrayed right so she'll
say whatever needs to be said to keep
them enthralled but that's humans that's
not Facebook well no what I mean is
someone creates an algorithm the
algorithm then generates a kind of
content that people get attached to
Rachel Maddow then sees here's a market
share I can take right based upon the
algorithmic manipulation so a better
example is black lives matter and police
brutality
videos that generate outrage get more
shares and more interactivity than
anything else and so Facebook was
inundated with police brutality videos
police brutality accounts for a
microscopic percentage of all police
interactions but they get clicks so you
have a generation of kids this is the
next component outside of the media
making money you had kids who were 15 16
years old at the dawn of Facebook
they go on Facebook all they see is
police brutality over and over and over
again because it was making money for
these companies then by the time they're
out of college they're 22 a few years
later it's 2012 2013 and they are
hypnotized believing the entire world is
police hunting down black people so
their whole perspective is Warped to an
insane degree Rachel Maddow and people
like her have found a captive audience
who believe in same things that they can
Pander to right but I have to say
specifically on that example I feel like
that one is very much a double-edged
sword like I don't believe that George
Floyd's killers killer would be in
prison if not for the algorithm doing
that because that would not have become
a national historian without it being a
national story would we have had that
video would it have gone that way and so
I feel like there's such a it's such a
double-edged but should he be in prison
oh that's there's a divide in this
country between concerns there is
absolutely really oh we we've gone over
that that story to a great degree when
the story first broke we were all very
much on the side of like whoa that was
really wrong of him to do and then when
the body camera footage got released we
were like wow the media lied to us about
everything noting like with George Floyd
yeah like George Floyd was on a speed
ball he had high doses of
methamphetamine and what else did he
have nicotine uh caffeine he was
shooting at a speed ball five drugs yeah
but he was strangled to death I mean
yeah technically I think well cause of
death was Cardiac Arrest but that might
have been due to asphyxiation no it was
no there were two um autopsies that came
out the family's autopsy said it was
strangulation and then the state coroner
said it was no but I watched the whole
trial and it was very clear that it was
um strangulation well I mean that wasn't
even contested by his lawyer well it's
it's not I'm not trying to get it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm down because I'm
willing I'm I'm willing to have the
argument you know he should be you you
know manslaughter at the very least but
the issue is that
um in there there's there's it's not so
clear-cut and you have you have you
probably have the the the more
conservative side of things saying it's
not clear-cut that he should be in jail
uh one example is even in the trial the
use of force expert for the for the
prosecution said that uh Chauvin would
have been entitled to use even more
Force than he had already used so there
I'm again I'm not saying you're wrong
I'm just saying there were issues where
people see it differently and so yeah I
actually just pulled up here from
mystateline.com I haven't checked it out
but an autopsy report confirmed George
Floyd died from a cardiac arrest which
was quote Complicated by law enforcement
subdual
um this was the cardiac arrest was
caused by him being strangulated that's
what it said well it says yeah it was
complicated it was caused by probably
complications due to law enforcement a
better example yeah we choked him until
he had a heart attack a better example
is probably like Kyle Rittenhouse that's
a perfect example I'm sure we totally
agree about that that was disgusting I
mean but this is what what happens when
um maybe it's even a better example than
that like Russia gate or what I
mentioned with Rachel Maddow and
claiming Republicans forged documents
there's there's a desperate need to
satisfy your subscribers
we don't do that we you know uh we don't
we just talk about what we want to talk
about sometimes people get mad at us
I've criticized people on the right and
also have people yelling at me and I'm
like dude whatever if you think I'm just
gonna Pander and then they're like it's
it's really amazing a cancel culture
does exist for everyone what does it
mean if you know it's not only on the
left for sure with the rise of
subscription model this is fascinating
what is the future of Journalism if
you're I mean how can you keep a
journalistic Enterprise afloat and try
and be the fourth estate and criticize
everything and everyone when you have to
have subscribers that'll leave if you
start criticizing the people they love
yeah so so the New York Times right now
91 of its readership are Democrats now
that takes a lot of work to get there
for the paper of record that's no that's
no easy feat you know like something
they did in the last five years just
like CNN you know in 2012 as recently as
2012 both CNN and Fox News had a
predominantly working class viewership
they had only 25 percent of both Fox and
CNN had a college degree over the course
of the last you know 10 years or
whatever CNN lost half of its working
class audience it signaled to working
class Libs this channel is no longer for
you how did it do that with wokeness
because wokeness is a smoke screen for a
class divide it's being perpetuated by
white liberal Elites who are literally
lining their pockets with this stuff you
know to avoid talking about a class
divide that they have benefited from
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast if you want
to watch live you can check out this
channel Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time